hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that comes as a suggestion
from angeline the muharraji
and it's a game from chess 24 banter
blitz session that yanni pom
she held on just24 uh he's playing
against the username alexgo05 and
this is uh no ordinary game it's uh well
especially since alex go5 is playing
against the world champs championship
challenger uh that is yanipanishi and
this is just uh well
it's a really a gem and it would be a
shame for you to miss it
so uh thank you very much for the
suggestion i don't think i would have
uh uh found or seen this game if it
wasn't for you so thanks for
thanks for that now let's uh check it
out nepo has the white pieces
and he opens with e4 and as usual the
time format on these
banter blitz sessions is three minutes
and zero seconds increment
so e4 we have e5 knight to f3 knight to
c6 and
bishop to c4 that we have bishop to c5
by alex go5
uh and here uh yes i know what you guys
are thinking but no it
did not happen nipple played c3 he went
for the main line of the joko piano
and now knight to f6 so just going for
the
standard stuff we have d4 by nipple e
captures on d4
uh and now comes b4 something that we
call on this channel the delayed evans
gambit and
there is a famous game that features
this movie it is daniel dubo versus
sergey
karakin uh it's been uh well some have
called it the the game of 2020. i myself
do consider it to be the game of 2020.
so if by any chance you haven't seen it
it will be the first link in the
description below do check it out
the game is just uh outstanding so that
being said
uh after b4 the bishop is under attack
and the bishop has to move so here we
have bishop back to b6
uh and then now comes e5 same as duba
played against karakin
and here after this knight was under
attack uh karakin went knight to e4 but
here in this game
uh we have d5 and this is an improvement
or
at least it should be on karakin's move
against dubo
and it's still not a new move this move
has been played before so the bishop is
under attack now the bishop can either
move
or we can trade a knight for bishop here
uh nepo decides to trade we have e
captures on f6
d captures on c4 and now uh there is a
game where queen to e2 check was played
uh or rather several games but here
nipple just plays uh g
f captures and g7 attacks the rook and
it is already as of move 9 that we have
a completely new game
so let's see how alex go5 deals with
this f captures and g7 move
so here we have rook the g8 you could
throw in a queen to e7 check but you can
always
throw this in so it's not really a
problem and
while nipple could castle here he
doesn't he says no it's not a problem
let's first get rid of this knight claim
the e5 square for r knight maybe weaken
the d4 square
and then uh if the queen delivers check
i'm just going to move my king to f1 and
then maybe later on i can play h4 h5 h6
maybe
maybe even keep this pawn here so let's
see how he goes about this he plays b5
attacks the knight
and now of course alex throws in queen
to e7 check
as one should now uh going for the queen
trade here doesn't really do anything
and it's not really in the spirit of the
opening so here king to f1
uh this is of course best and now knight
the e5 as the queen now also helps
with the defense of this pawn and now
nepo just grabs the pawn he plays knight
captures on d4
and here nipple already agrees that he
his position is
really really bad and that maybe he can
uh you know
maybe develop his pieces and
miraculously save the game and
get some sort of a draw instead of
knight captures on d4 he also mentions
that bishop to a3 might be a nice
in-between move
and uh in some similar lines like in the
evan's gambit
uh you might throw in a bishop to a3 now
and then but okay knight captures on e4
like we said this is a three-minute
blitz game
and now bishop to g4 attacking nipples
queen here on d1
uh we have f3 taking care of that and
now
uh this move what's interesting this
move happened instantly so as soon as f3
was played
black went for a queen side castle and
here he says uh i don't care what you do
i'm completely
destroying you here you don't really
have a good move to play the the rook
isn't getting into the game king really
can't do all that much the queen is
stuck here
the knight cannot move uh you could
develop this knight or bishop doesn't
really do anything
so for the lack of a better move nipple
just decides to capture the bishop on g4
he plays
f captures on g4 uh and uh
uh what what do you play here as black
well there is one
extremely good move and that is queen to
f6 with
check so what do you play here uh after
this queen to f6 check nipple played
queen king to g1 but you don't really
have any better options i mean getting
the king into the middle of the board it
doesn't really do
anything in knight f3 that's pointless
the queen is hanging
so keen to g1 it's bad but it's uh not
as bad as
maybe the other squares for the king and
now uh the position is completely
winning for black like i said
so feel free to pause the video here and
win this game in the nicest way possible
for
our friend alex go5 here while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding
any move here because any move is
winning in this position whether you
just
grab the pawn whether you go something
like knights to d3 and then do whatever
or you can just go for the absolutely
most forcing line
and that is rook captures on d4 this was
played in the game
and it kind of looks weird because well
the queen also defends this square but
there is one problem
this queen indirectly defends this
square as well and that's a huge problem
now you don't really have an option here
if you don't capture the rook wherever
the rook moves it's just going to be
checkmate for example queen moves rook
to d1 will be a double check from the
rook and from the bishop
let's say you play queen to c2 it's just
rook to d1 checkmate there's nowhere for
for the king to go
uh and uh well you have to capture it so
here nipple kept
captured on d4 but now comes bishop
capture sunday for
queen captures uh and there really now
is
nothing else but to win the game and
that of course is knight to f3 we reach
the position from the thumbnail
uh the knight now has to be captured or
you don't have to capture it but then
the knight captures queen
so here nipple has to capture and now
queen captures on d4
not only winning the queen but also
delivering check and the forking this
rook on a1 so that's that's a
you know terrible luck for nipple here
so came to g2
now comes queen captures on a1 and now
bishop to h6 and here
nepal said that he's actually reasonably
happy because he gets to defend his pawn
on g7 and maybe he can
still do something here so here we have
c3
and here uh nippo uh remarks that
his opponent is playing as well as mr
stockfish here or maybe even better
so what do you do here yeah of course
you cannot capture this the queen is
defending the c3 pawn c2 is coming
it's a really really tough position to
face nipple played rook to c1
but just queen to b2 with check okay the
rook is defended by the bishop but still
it's a very very ugly king to g3 we have
c2 now attacking the knight
and there is no saving the knight
because if we play knight here then the
bishop no longer defends the rook we can
just gobble up the rook here
so instead nepo had to give up the night
knight the a3 was played but now just
queen captures on a3 and this is uh
you know absolutely demolition happening
here
uh rook captures on c2 he he does win
the the pass pawn but now uh
now comes queen to d3 attacking the rook
here also going after the b4 pawn
we have rooked the c1 and just queen
captures on b5 and here
you could resign this but nipple is a
bit better on the clock as this was a
three minute blitz game
uh nipple is some i i think minute and a
half minutes 40 seconds and uh
his opponent is below that maybe some 35
seconds on the clock
so here we have h4 and now c6
just a nice safety move with h5 nipple
continues pushing his king side pawns
now queen to e5 with check king to g2
and now you don't really want to do
anything
uh you know to prolong the game you just
give up the rook win the bishop and then
it's queen against rook and
that's all there is so here bishop
captures we have queen captures
and now rook to e1 but it's uh all for
nothing king 37 rook d1 check
nipple will try to win some time maybe
even try and flag his opponent to rook
to e1
and here no i misspoke there here the
situation on the clock is nipple around
one minute versus 35 seconds uh so here
we have queen to b2 with
check going after this pawn king j3 now
just queen captures on
a2 we have h6 by nipple uh trying
something
we have c5 black now starts pushing the
other pass pawn
and rook to e5 uh here we have
king to d6 chasing the rook away rook to
g5 going after these pawns here
we have c4 and now rook to g7
we have queen to b1 now defending this
pawn but now
rook captures on f7 we have c3
the pass pawn continues marching forward
and now rook to f6
with check king e5 we have rook to f7
and now just
c2 and there really isn't all that much
you can do now
rook captures on h7 was played but now
another queen comes into the game also
there is now a discovery on the rook
so rook the e7 check king to f6 and now
rook to e4
and here nepo can basically hope for
some sort of a
maybe uh if everything gets gobbled up
then maybe he can get some sort of a
stalemate or maybe his opponent can lose
on time but his opponent is very precise
queen to g1 check
king to f4 and now queen beat to c1 and
it was
in this position on move 44 that ian
pony should resign the game
and this incredible incredible victory
was achieved by mr alex go5 who we know
nothing about
uh but that is his username so here you
resign because you only have one legal
move
uh that's rook to e3 and after that the
queen captures the rook and that's just
checkmate the king has no squares
and it's just uh this is just a
masterpiece
how to play against this delayed evans
gambit line
and nepal said that if he knew that he
if he was playing against a player of
such caliber that he would have done
something different but
you know don't we all say that when we
lose such a game
so uh very interesting does this
sometimes happen to you when you play
online maybe you feel like
okay this was just weird i mean okay my
opponent
maybe is a bit uh i mean it's different
when we play because okay you play
against the higher rated opponent you
might have your dots but nippo it's very
unlikely that uh he's playing against uh
uh an unknown higher rated opponent uh
i mean there there are you know like
maybe two of them
it could be uh but uh it seems that it
happens to everyone and then
maybe you just figure out okay maybe i
didn't play all that well
uh but here it's uh it's not easy to
pinpoint nipples mistake uh
just like that i mean he he could have
played some better moves but it's a
blitz game it's a three minute blitz
game of course everyone can play a bit
of a better move here and there
but there is one position where nipple
could have played a better move and i
know you guys
which position that is so for those of
you who get it right uh
do write in the comment section below
and i will uh for for those of you who
get it first i will pin your message for
everyone else to see
uh where was the moment where nepo uh
could have played a much better move
uh have at it so that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank kd nuggets
derek king jean-guaran david kimura and
san mitamine for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your one of suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world
the ftx cup starts tomorrow so we are
going to be covering that as it's the
strongest tournament
ever as they say and with the biggest
prize fund
so yeah like i said thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your weekend